hey youtubers it's Charlie and they just
posted the first episode of Star Wars
rebels so this is gonna be my
non-spoilery review I'm assuming most of
you haven't had the chance to see it yet
just because it's on the Disney XD app
so next week whenever they aired on TV
I'll do a top 10 video with full
spoilers I am gonna be doing weekly
videos for all the episodes I might even
do like a fun Star Wars theme giveaway
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you like talking about
Star Wars we would love to have you on
the team it's an amazing show I mean
anyone who liked the Clone Wars is gonna
love rebels the episode the first
episode is called spark of rebellion it
introduces all the big heroes and
villains along with explaining what's
going on in the galaxy the series takes
place five years before episode four so
presumably whenever they end the series
it'll be just as Princess Leia is being
chased down by the Star Destroyer in the
opening moments of the movie the cast
and crew features a ton of familiar
faces basically like all the Clone Wars
production people just got moved on to
rebels Simon Kinberg was a really
notable addition he's writing for the
series he's one of the people that's
working on the new Star Wars movie so
there's a lot of overlap between the TV
show people and the movie people if
you've been watching my Star Wars movie
videos and you have a broad idea of what
the movies are going to look like you'll
be able to see some pretty clear
indicators that they're trying to link
these shows up across time and space I
think one of the biggest things that I
paid attention to going into the episode
completely fresh was the voice cast they
all did an amazing job but the most
recognizable people are easily Steve
Blum Vanessa Marshall and Freddie Prinze
jr. if you're a big fan of Young Justice
legend Decorah Cowboy Bebop
or you were a human being in the 90s you
will instantly recognize all these
voices jason isaacs ii was a part of the
cast but he really had like a brief
cameo so I'm gonna wait till he comes in
a bigger episode to talk about him more
even if you haven't seen the episode yet
and you don't know anything about the
show you could look at these people on
paper and just assume it's gonna be good
you know thankfully that was the case
there's always the chance for it to go
bad even if you have an a-list cast
Freddie Prinze jr. was totally a ton of
fun as the main character he's feeling
like the obi-wan role he'll be mentoring
slash training ezra played by taylor
gray whenever their teams in between
missions they're like a lovable band of
rogues that are part scoundrel part hero
i mean it totally be boring if they were
just good all the time i mean they have
to break the library once in a while I
feel like just Whedon fans will draw
lot of references to the cast of Firefly
both shows have like this amazing core
group of characters and that's really
what I think is gonna be most important
but obviously the show looks amazing I
don't necessarily think that Freddie
Prinze is like the Captain Mal he's not
that big of a scoundrel
but I do think he's nailing the Jedi
parts of his character like his
character is a Jedi who survived the
purge so he's gonna have a lot of like
Jedi Padawan moments and I feel like
those are gonna be the hardest to do
based on the characters he's played in
other movies and TV shows I think being
a lovable scoundrel is gonna come really
easy to him as an actor it's playing the
Jedi Master that's the hard part
like people have to be able to take you
seriously and laugh at you at the same
time it's really easy for someone to
sound silly whenever they're trying to
speechify in Jedi mode the rest of the
voice cast didn't go out of screen time
so I'll talk more about their characters
whenever they get like really big
moments in episodes but honestly when
you look at who they are
you tend to focus more on the Star Wars
specific things like the plot the sights
the sounds and the giant Death Star
looming in the distance speaking of
stories you guys will be really happy to
know that rebels is gonna be canon so
things that happen in the show will
affect things that happen in the movies
don't worry though you don't have to
have watched Clone Wars to understand
what's going on but there is a very
notable appearance from James Taylor's
obi-wan Kenobi and the Disney people did
like you Clone Wars fans a giant solid
they officially consider Clone Wars as
canon maybe not a hundred percent but
for all intents and purposes ahsoka and
everyone are cannon I didn't follow
Clone Wars for its entire run but I know
a lot of you are like hardcore fans
they'll probably be really happy to know
that yes it's gonna became they're not
just throwing it in a garbage can I
don't know if they have any plans to
include those characters and rebels but
they included obi-wan so maybe but just
to talk a little bit about the animation
in the visual style just because it
completely melted my face off it was
amazing a lot of the episode deals with
setting up what's going on in the galaxy
and just you know visually kind of
creating this universe and showing you
what it's going to be like it's a time
period we haven't seen yet but it's
instantly recognizable even if you
haven't been watching the cartoons the
animation does bear some similarities to
the computer animation style of Clone
Wars but all the textures just look at
their crank 2:11 I don't know if it's
because the animation software has
gotten more sophisticated or if it was
just a create
decision to spend more resources on that
kind of thing but everything just looks
so much more steampunky in Episode four
--is-- like all the lines are clean and
everything pops with this amazing color
but it still bears a lot of visual
influence from the original trilogy you
know like really dirty really lived in
part of me thinks that JJ Abrams has
influenced a lot of this and it's just
kind of trickled down through the movies
they're working on into the TV show
they're trying to create a unified Star
Wars Cinematic Universe just like Marvel
so the show has the opportunity to kind
of lay some of the visual groundwork for
what the universe looks like JJ Abrams
has just decided to go with a more
classic visual style and when I say
classic I just mean to differentiate the
visual style of the original trilogy
with the prequels so they pay a lot of
homage to the original trilogy in the
visual style but they also do it in the
story too at least structurally they
basically take a lot of the big WTF
moments from the original trilogy and
kind of repurpose them in interesting
ways like we see a really badass speeder
bike chase that hits all the same story
beats from the one in Episode six we see
a very familiar prison block seen even
the hyperspace sequence like the way
they make it look visually is very
similar to the ones from the movies it
definitely feels like the episode is a
love letter to the original trilogy
mostly because they love it and they're
trying to honor it but it also feels
like they're trying to prepare us for
these new movies and what they're gonna
look like I'm interested to see if the
visual style of rebels like how much
that changes between now and when we see
episode 7 because both teams the movie
team and the show team are communicating
a lot a really good example is the
episode 7 supposed stormtrooper helmets
they look like they could be future
versions of the helmets we see in the
episode so it seems like they're making
minor adjustments just so it all fits
together in this larger can and they're
trying to create so whenever you sit
down to watch the episode just try to
see if you recognize any moments from
the movies they're really easy to spot -
there's a certain amount of subtext but
the show's written so that a young child
could follow the broad themes older fans
will totally enjoy a few well-placed
Wilhelm screams that was another really
interesting thing about the episode is
they had a lot of you know very Star
Wars specific sounds like Foley sounds
but they didn't trip over each other and
I was able to pick them up even when I
was listening to other characters talk
it's just like a Star Wars geek thing
I've always done since before the
prequels it's like a game you know where
did this sound
first appear or where did this noise
come from if you want to be really
hardcore about it you could try and pick
them all out you'll have a lot of fun
there's also a lot of familiar music
cues from Episode four I just say in
general the story structure of the
episode mostly takes from Episode four
but there are a few epic Empire Strikes
Back and Jedi moments I only had a few
minor complaints about the episode one
it was really short I felt like this
should have gone for like an hour and a
half easy but they're also making it
really hard for people to watch
especially if you live outside of the
United States the Disney XD app and the
website where you can watch it for free
doesn't let you watch unless you get
Disney XD as part of your cable TV
subscription that's not really the bad
part not all the cable providers they
list them on their website are part of
that deal so like if you have Time
Warner you cannot watch this because
Time Warner does not have a partnership
with Disney XD so that's my only real
complaint is this they're not making it
very easy for people to watch the
episode we'll be on TV
October 3rd so hopefully you'll all be
able to see it by then but if you have
access to it on the website you should
totally watch it don't wait since
that'll be next Friday my Knicks rebels
videos gonna be my top 10 favorite
moments from the episode with you know
full spoilers and after Friday on
October 13th the show's gonna move to
Monday nights at 9 p.m. Eastern Time
what I'm gonna do is because Gotham airs
before it I'll be posting Gotham videos
Monday nights and then my rebel's videos
will just post Tuesday mornings I will
still be live tweeting during the
episode so you can find my social links
in the description if you're not
following me already I am pretty good
about giving updates on Twitter and
Facebook about when videos are coming to
I will be adding all the new videos to
my giant Star Wars playlist here so you
can click on that to watch all my other
rebels and movie related videos and you
can click here to get my breakdown of
the latest Legend of Korra book 4
trailer so thank you so much for
watching now let's all high five and
we'll meet up for some Doctor Who
tomorrow